it's not what he had in mind but
Vladimir Putin has mobilized an army of
Russians fleeing the country crammed in
their thousands in the narrow gorge on
its border with Georgia desperate to
escape
for those who get through to the
Georgian sides there is huge relief
how do you feel now you've crossed the
border
[Laughter]
exhausted but happy I guess
relieved yes
10 000 Russians have crossed a day here
since Putin's mobilization decree almost
a week ago some fleeing call-out papers
they've already been sent like Nick on
the run now to avoid fighting in Ukraine
uh I want to live for Russia because
I'm an engineering scientist and
my government who wants me
wants to make a meat from me
the queue of vehicles at the Georgia
border backs up for miles with similar
scenes reported in Kazakhstan and
Mongolia tube Russians are voting with
their feet against Putin's war and his
call-up plans we've met an engineer an
I.T specialist a nuclear physicist all
who've given up their jobs and are
simply walking out of Russia this is a
mass Exodus in which Russia is
hemorrhaging some of its brightest and
its best a brain drain that could take
years to recover from
it had taken four days for this family
of six to get out Vitalia Maria leaving
with their four children Putin's call-up
they say was the last straw my boy is
17. next year he will be taken to the
Army the war is not going to end
tomorrow if he goes what did I race him
for Putin we're not going back until
there's a new government and the new
president
they've left everything behind they have
no plans Beyond a taxi ride to Georgia's
capital their future is completely
uncertain but still preferable they say
to life in Russia under Putin Dominic
wyghorn Sky News on Russia's border with
Georgia